[Musique]
le Parti conservateur par contre un plan
de gros bon sens
contrairement au bloc walkis et à juste
un trou d'eau notre plan c'est que les
criminels violentes et récidiviste qui
sont arrêtés de nouveau soit en prison
jusqu'au moment que leur peine est
complété
le système de libération sous caution
les provinces et les chefs de police
réclament des règles plus strictes
depuis plusieurs semaines déjà pour
éviter les crimes commis par des
récidivistes en attente de leur procès
la réponse du gouvernement projet de loi
C48 déposer cette semaine ne va pas
assez loin au goût des conservateurs
alors les libéraux sont-ils trop
prudents ou les conservateurs vont-ils
trop loin voyons voir ce qu'on pense que
collaborateurs étaient animateurs de
midi info et si première Chantal Hébert
et chroniqueur au Toronto Star et au
magazine L'actualité Michel CEG est
analyste politique à la presse des
radios Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour Chantal je commence avec vous
quand j'écoutais la réponse de Monsieur
poignet cette semaine j'avais des
effluves de du mandat de monsieur Harper
il me semble que ça ressemble beaucoup à
ce que l'on a entendu dans le passé
est-ce que c'est efficace ce genre
d'argumentaire là
de façon législative ou juridique pas
particulièrement parce qu'il y a un
paquet de projets de loi de du temps de
Steven Harper en matière de loi et ordre
qui ont été déboutés devant les
tribunaux parce que
inconstitutionnel et dans le cas de la
proposition de Monsieur Polliat qui
inclut l'idée que si on est accusé une
deuxième fois mais pas encore jugé on
n'aurait pas droit d'être libéré sous
caution c'est une façon de dire la
présomption de l'innocence compte plus
la deuxième fois ça passera
vraisemblablement pas le test des
tribunaux mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est quelque part une fois de temps en
temps ce serait plus simple pour
Monsieur polliath de juste prendre le
crédit de ce que le gouvernement vient
de faire en disant vous voyez on a
poussé on a fait écho Premier ministre
des provinces on a fait écho chef de
police qui dans l'ensemble satisfaire du
projet de loi de David la médecine en
passant et
si on avait été au gouvernement on a
réagi plus vite plutôt que d'essayer
d'en rajouter une couche qui tient plus
ou moins la ouate et qui a l'air d'être
ajouté juste pour dire nous autres on
est les plus tôt
[Musique]
un projet de loi sur une mesure très
précise les libération sous cautionne
donc avant procès il y avait beaucoup de
pression sur le gouvernement Trudeau les
provinces territoires associations de
police groupe de victimes réclamait que
lorsqu'on a déjà été accusé ou reconnu
coupable de crime violent avec une arme
bon on ne soit pas systématiquement
libéré sous caution que le fardeau de la
preuve soit inversé et c'est à ceux
qu'on répond donc on a je pense trouver
un équilibre qui pour l'instant semble
adéquat mais cet équilibre là il est
toujours fragile le système de justice
pénale et on l'a vu sous ce stimuler
lorsqu'on a commencé à jouer dedans on
peut rapidement le déséquilibrer il faut
que ce soit évidemment conforme à la
charte des droits et libertés parce que
oui les criminels ou ceux qui sont
accusés ont aussi des droits on est non
coupable jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
faut que on envoie un message à la
population il faut que l'opinion
publique faut que les gens gardent
confiance envers le système de justice
pour pas qu'elle soit une passoire non
plus faut que les gens doivent à
l'impression qu'on est bien protégé
alors il y a ça ici et donc cet
équilibre là il est toujours assez fin
délicat alors commençons par ça voir si
effectivement en renversant le fardeau
de la preuve pour certains crimes graves
violents on peut avoir un peu plus de de
de
sécurité parce qu'il y a eu des codes
très médiatisés dans les derniers mois
au Canada puis on verra s'il faut
ajuster ensuite mais de partir avec une
espèce de réforme totale ou qui serait
battu devant les tribunaux dans deux ou
trois ans comme ça a été le cas des fois
précédent ça avance pas grand chose non
plus
et d'autre part il faut pas
partir pression que que la libération
sous caution est automatique dans le
moment c'est pas le cas
et dans les propos de Monsieur poillière
il y a cette fausse impression que dans
le moment le système fonctionne c'est
automatique que vous on vous accuse d'un
deuxième crime violent et zappe vous en
avez j'ai vu des chiffres cette semaine
qui montrait que 70% des gens qui sont
en attente qui sont dans les prisons en
Ontario dans les centres de détention
sont en attente d'un procès donc on
n'aura pas donné de libération
succession alors la discrétion des juges
existe et comme dans le temps c'était
venu un peu on dirait qu'on veut dicter
au juge
une espèce de formule obligatoire qui
fait pour tout le monde et jusqu'à
présent cette formule là pas résister
aux tests des tribunaux
pas mal de jeux qui ont trouvé que ça
allait à l'encontre de la Constitution
on pourrait dire qu'il était un petit
peu causé partie mais c'est néanmoins un
fait que les juges ont actuellement
beaucoup de discrétion
la raison pour laquelle monsieur poignet
avant ce discours là clairement c'est
qu'il a l'impression que ça lui permet
de faire du millage quelque part ou que
ça résonne chez des gens est-ce que
c'est une impression qui est fondée ou
c'est un effecteur est-ce que d'après
vous ça ça la résonance chez les lecteur
moyen
il y a toujours un marché pour le
discours de loin et l'ordre la question
c'est est-ce que on est dans des
circonstances particulières qui font que
les gens se sentent plus
insécure qui sentent moins sécuritaire
actuellement qui pensent que il y a un
problème de criminalité plus grand mais
ceci est indiquent pas nécessairement ça
alors il faudra voir mais évidemment ça
c'est une impression si on veut créer
qui manque il dit c'est très grave ce
qui se passe dans nos rues puis c'est
effrayant monsieur poignet fait un peu
discours là aussi une fois de temps en
temps c'est sûr que qu'on peut créer la
demande mais est-ce qu'elle est là pour
vrai ou si elle est là juste si on
l'agète ça c'est notre affaire non on
verra où ça où ça se dirige le projet
doit être déposé la semaine dernière
alors mais la semaine dernière il y a
aussi une déclaration intéressante de
Monsieur Drainville durant une rencontre
éditoriale avec nos collègues du devoir
à Montréal on va vous faire entendre la
déclaration et l'excuse qui s'en est
suivie puis on revient là-dessus
pourquoi un député de mériterait
le job d'enseignante à la job de député
là tu étais en train de me dire que ça
se comporte s'il y a des personnes qui
se sont senties blessés
surtout des enseignants des enseignants
oui je m'excuse auprès auprès de ces
personnes là
[Musique]
c'est sûrement pas bien passé auprès des
enseignants Alex déclaration là
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec monsieur
drinville qui était député puis plus
animateur de radio comment
rencontres éditoriales de
généralement c'est pas filmé mais de
voir après cette habitude là depuis
maintenant deux ou trois ans puis ça
donne ça fait en sorte que ce genre de
phrase-là circule un peu plus
qu'auparavant je pense en fait que
l'irritation à la base de Bernard
Drainville vient de du passage difficile
du gouvernement en entier de François
Legault depuis à peu près 10 jours
est-ce que Bernard drinville aurait été
piqué par la question tout à fait
légitime de Michel David s'il n'avait
pas eu à défendre la hausse de son
propre salaire de 30% parce que le
projet de loi déposé par son
gouvernement veut que aussi le salaire
de base des députés de 30%, ça peut
paraître 30000 dollars et ça tombe à un
moment où on essaie de renouveler les
conventions
des employés de la fonction publique
dont les enseignants et qu'on leur offre
9% sur 5 ans un peu plus pour certains
cas de métiers mais on est assez loin
quand même 30% disons-le et donc ça ça
entre en ligne de compte ça crée de la
frustration et les députés ils sont pas
essentibles au fait que le message donc
il est plus difficile à faire passer
alors on se sent piquer un peu plus
rapidement par les questions des
journalistes sur cette question là il y
a aucun député ou ministre qu'on a
interrogé depuis que ce projet de loi
était déposé qui s'est bien défendu ce
qui était capable de l'expliquer
correctement pourquoi les députés
avaient besoin d'une hausse de salaire
je pense qu'ils ont besoin d'une hausse
de salaire personnellement à la hauteur
de 30% sans toucher au fond de pension
ça c'est une autre question mais on a de
la difficulté à le défendre la
difficulté à l'expliquer puis ça fait en
sorte qu'on a des dérapages comme ça
dans des rencontres éditoriales ça
s'ajoute à Simon Jeannin barrette qui a
eu des difficultés la fin de semaine
passée à expliquer la nomination d'un
juge à la Cour du Québec qui est avec
les bons amis puis refaire des des
rondes de candidats dans des régions où
ça fait pas notre affaire alors là on a
on a un message le chaotique depuis une
semaine puis je pense que ça se ressent
au gouvernement alors on est un peu plus
irritable quand on vient de les
questions des collègues Michel ensuite
Michel pourquoi pourquoi la réaction
comment vous l'expliquer vous
on dirait que le gouvernement le goût
depuis le score favorineux du patron
devant son congrès a perdu ses repères
on peut faire on peut faire un peu
n'importe quoi c'est ça qui est le
problème il y a d'autres choses qui sont
venues s'ajouter à ça il y a une salaire
des députés il y a un salaire du chef de
cabinet du premier ministre qui va faire
100000 dollars de plus que son patron le
Premier ministre quand même un peu
bizarre
il y a toujours des choses comme ça et
pour lesquelles le gouvernement n'a pas
préparé le terrain n'avait pas
d'argumentaire n'avait pas
distribué de toute évidence de ligne de
presse à ces députés alors ils ont eu
l'air d'être complètement désemparé par
des réactions du public qui était somme
toute assez prévisibles alors
c'est ça qui est le plus compliqué
actuellement à gérer pour le
gouvernement de gauche c'est le fait que
ils ont pas l'air à être présent aux
réactions de l'opinion publique alors
qu'elles sont ma foi assez normal
ça c'est il y a une espèce de de reprise
en main qui doit être faite au niveau du
gouvernement là parce que c'est quand
même remarquable le patron soit score
soviétique à son congrès puis dans la
semaine d'après tout cas
c'est comme ça on n'était pas préparé à
ça effectivement manque de préparation
Chantal
il y a la préparation il y a aussi le
fait que c'est peut-être est-ce que
c'est le bon moment de mettre
l'augmentation le projet de loi pour
l'augmentation de salaire en pleine
négociation que les travailleurs de la
fonction publique problème de timing
mais en évidence de deux choses deux
choses d'abord à l'évidence pour on
repasse pas pour le bon moment bon
moment dans le calendrier du mandat oui
tôt et le très mauvais moment au moment
où on est en train de faire des des
négociations collectives premier
problème deuxième problème
si on était pour faire ça c'était
prévisible que la réaction serait celle
qu'on a vu donc de pas préparer une des
une défense une façon d'expliquer ce
qu'on faisait dans ce temps-là ça envoie
le message que finalement c'est
inexplicable mais et puis dans le code
Bernard je pense que il faut ajouter
qu'il a dit à cette table éditoriale ou
qui a défendu à cette table et tutoriale
un peu le contraire de ce qui avait dit
devant une proposition d'augmentation de
salaire des députés quand lui-même était
dans l'opposition alors là on est sur du
terrain particulièrement glissant
et à chaque fois que ces glissant il se
défend généralement en glissant un peu
plus le rappelez-vous le laissez-moi
tranquille avec les GES quand on perdait
du troisième lien c'est pas des phrases
qui vous sortent c'est comme quelqu'un
qui prend sa pelle et qui dit je me
rends en train de me creuser un trou
allons-y gaiement
ne pas sortir le GES les autres
explications mais effectivement je
drague ouais c'est pas la première fois
alors qu'est-ce que ça fait au
négociations dans le secteur public
je commencerai à trouver que mon
gouvernement ne m'aide pas beaucoup dans
ces déclarations dans les projets de loi
qu'on dépose cette semaine à la fin de
sortie en disant qu'elle était un peu
irritée par l'inertie des négociations
et je peux la comprendre et je pense
qu'il y a une tactique syndicale dans la
façon de négocier depuis bien des rondes
de négociation au Québec ou les
syndicats pense avoir un levier de
négociation uniquement quand ils ont un
mandat de grève de leurs employés et
pour atteindre le mandat de grève mais
ça prend d'abord le médiateur puis pour
avoir le médiateur il faut que les
choses traînent un peu à longueur et je
pense que il y a une raison pour
laquelle Sonia label est irrité mais en
même temps elle se présente à la table
de négociation avec deux ou trois
boulets où je fais maintenant avec la
hausse de salade et députés des hauts
fonctionnaires des conseillers
politiques dans le cas du Premier
ministre mais c'est pas le seul qui a eu
une augmentation de salaire les
déclarations de Bernard Drainville en
éducation alors là un moment donné pour
elle c'est sûr que c'est plus complexe
elle fait partie de ce gouvernement là
elle peut parler à ses collègues
peut-être un peu sur le bureau Conseil
des ministres pour dire ce serait temps
qu'on remette nos choses en ordre mais
c'est clair que pour elle ça annonce un
été un petit peu plus complexe et pour
effectivement bon on verra ce que ça va
donner l'été va être complexe a bien
niveau pour bien des dossiers on n'a pas
parlé de gérant étrangères aujourd'hui
vous savez pourquoi on va en parler la
semaine prochaine parce que on va
finalement avoir entre les mains la
recommandation de Monsieur Johnston ça
risque alimenté un peu la conversation
avec Chantal Michel merci à vous trois
au revoir au revoir